after another disputed police shooting
of a black man in wisconsin more cities
burn
the rnc begins its big roll out tonight
and joe biden suggests he might lock
down the entire american economy
again over covet i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like the government spying on you
then visit expressvpn.com
to stay anonymous well there are actual
serious things happening in the world
the good news is that
many in the media are focusing on you
know the white house rose garden or
kellyanne conway's marriage we'll get to
all of that a little bit later on in the
program but we begin today
with another disputed police shooting
this one in kenosha
wisconsin this is receiving all sorts of
attention because again there's video
footage of a fragment
of the actual shooting incident and what
you will see here
is disturbing so there is your warning
what you see here is a black man
his name is uh is jacob
okay his name according to cnn is
i guess they're now releasing it so i
was a little hesitant about saying it
uh so jacob blake is the man's name well
you can see in this particular case is
jacob blake walking away from the police
officers who are telling him to stop
they have their police
weapons drawn on him as he is walking
away he walks over to
his car it is unclear whether he has
something in his hand or if he doesn't
have something in his hand
it is unclear whether there is something
in the car whether there isn't something
in the car
and then they shoot him when he reaches
into the guard he's completely ignoring
them as all of this goes on he's been
shot
either seven or nine times by various
accounts and uh he is now
in i believe serious condition so he is
still alive
this led off a series of riots last
night in kenosha
wisconsin now here's the thing we
literally don't know what happened here
okay all you know is what's on the tape
i said all you know is that there's some
white police officers they're following
this black man who's walking away from
them they have their guns drawn they
have no idea why their guns are drawn
we have no idea what happened
immediately previous to this we have
heard an account that he was breaking up
some sort of fight between two women but
we literally have no confirmation of
this we don't know whether that is true
the only thing that we know in this
particular case is what is on the tape
and what is already on record we know
that what is on record is that he has a
history of assaulting police he also has
passed charges for domestic abuse
and a sex crime as well and there's a
warrant for his arrest that is what we
know documentarily okay so
that doesn't mean that the shooting is
good it doesn't mean that the shooting
is bad i'm just telling you what we know
at this point what we don't know
is whether he was reaching for a gun we
don't know what's in the car we don't
know anything
so the responsible position would be in
this particular case you hold off on
judgment
maybe it's a bad shooting maybe it's not
a bad shooting maybe it was racially
driven although we literally have no
evidence of that
maybe it's not racially driven we do not
know what happened here right that would
be the responsible
play here by the media that would be the
responsible play here by your political
class
unfortunately responsibility matters not
on twitter and it matters not in
american public life anymore
instead everybody immediately jumps to
their pre-existing
biases and that is particularly true on
the blm left which has decided that this
is yet another example of an unarmed
black man being shot for no reason at
all by the police
for racial reasons and our politicians
are simply repeating this and so are
media
the headline from cnn today wisconsin
police
shoot black men as children watch from a
car attorney says
okay so we're now just taking at face
value
what the attorney says with no
additional evidence provided by the cops
the cops have not provided an account of
what has happened as of yet at this hour
according to cnn two wisconsin police
officers are on leave monday as state
authorities investigate why a black man
was shot multiple times
in the back as he entered the driver's
side door of an suv official said
among the witnesses to the sunday
evening shooting in kenosha with a man's
three sons attorney ben crump in the
american civil liberties union said the
man identified
by the wisconsin governor as jacob blake
is in serious condition
and fighting for his life krom posted a
short video of the shooting garnering
almost 700 thousand views sparking
protests that led county officials to
institute a curfew
until 7am that would be 6 a.m eastern
time on
monday protesters overnight broke
windows and spread
graffiti at a kenosha county
administrative building and torched
vehicles at a nearby auto dealership
by the way the torching of the vehicles
at the auto dealership was
somewhat ironic considering that the
auto dealership literally had a giant
sign out front that said black lives
matter didn't matter they torched the
vehicles anyway
a fire i mean you can see the video of
it it's incredible i mean these are
these these these cars are being burned
i know the cars had anything to do with
anything apparently nothing but they
were being burned
and right outside there is a uh there's
a big sign that says
black lives matter so that's exciting
stuff happening over in wisconsin
a fire was started at the county
courthouse officers in tactical gear
formed a line to protect the public
safety building according to
the local wisn cnn affiliate kenosha's
about 40 minutes south of
milwaukee we also have tape of in
kenosha wisconsin
we have tape of some blm
allies maybe antifa members because the
guy's white who
walks up literally to a sheriff's
vehicle with a long gun drawn pointing
at the sheriff
they stop they literally are pointing
weapons
at a uh at a sheriff's vehicle
and um everything is going really well
everything is going really really well
and naturally this would be a good time
for our political class so you know
maybe take the temperature down a little
bit wouldn't this be a good time for
our public leaders to say things like
this is under full investigation the
police officers have been taken off duty
while we investigate the incident and
find out what happened here
wouldn't that be a good time to say
let's let the process work every single
officer involved shooting in the united
states is fully investigated
that does not mean they're not incidents
where officers go unpunished for things
they should be punished for
that does happen okay but we have no
evidence that's going to happen here
we have no evidence what exactly
happened here and if you are the head of
your state's
law enforcement body right let's say
you're the governor of the state
wouldn't you say at this point you're
the head of the executive branch
wouldn't you say at this point let's
wait for the process to work
but no our politicians have decided
there's much more hay to be made
in suggesting openly that this is a
racially driven bad police shooting
based on no evidence whatsoever yet
right just based on that fragmentary
tape
police said they were called to respond
to a domestic disturbance it is unclear
who called 9-1-1 or what happened before
the recording begins it's not clear from
the video if both of the officers opened
fire there two officers the second
officer has his gun out as the shots are
heard
all officers are cooperating neither
officer has been identified
dci which is the department of internal
affairs over there is continuing to
review evidence and determine the facts
of this incident and will turn over
investigative reports to a prosecutor
following a complete and thorough
investigation the statement said
hey so what did our what did our
wonderful members of the political class
do here instead of taking down the
temperature and it doesn't matter if you
take down the temperature here
because we have seen situations already
like within the last couple of weeks
in which bad accounts of police
shootings went viral
and caused actual riots right the
chicago loop riots were caused
by online rumors that a child had been
shot unarmed by a police officer
it turned out not to be true at all it
turned out that there was a man shooting
at police officers who was shot didn't
matter people went riot in the chicago
loop
by the way rioting is not justified even
if there's a bad shooting
we have answers for that in this country
that is called the police officer goes
to jail
that is called the police officer is
dragged up on charges as they should be
if you do something wrong
okay the the answer to this is never
burning crap in the streets
but our political class at least on the
left have decided it is mostly important
that they get their
spilkas out on twitter that they go out
there and they then they show their
their narrative their narrative empathy
on twitter
and if you don't jump to a conclusion on
twitter you're considered bad right if
you wait too long
if you wait too long then you're cons if
you say maybe we should wait for the
evidence and then i'll say
that this fits into a pattern of x y or
z then you are considered bad
and wrong and terrible our political
incentive system rewards people who jump
out front and back a narrative before
the evidence is in
and then what if the evidence doesn't
back it we just ignore it just goes away
right we just rewrite the situation the
factual situation in order to meet the
narrative
this is what happened with michael brown
people still list michael brown among
quote unquote victims of police
shootings despite the fact that the
obama doj
found that shooting to be justified
despite the fact that local prosecutors
twice
found that shooting to be justified
michael brown in all the lists is always
included in the list
freddie gray is always included in the
list of wrongful police killings despite
the fact that there was a full
investigation into freddie gray's death
and he was not actually murdered by the
police
he died because they didn't buckle him
into the back of the police van properly
and then he banged his head
unfortunately on the back of the police
van right
that is the actual autopsy showing there
was a full investigation done
all of rayshard brooks is listed among
the victims of police violence even
though he tried to tase two
separate officers and was firing a taser
and officer when he was shot
the the individual facts of the
circumstances don't matter they don't
matter at all
only the narrative matters and once the
narrative has been set
then the victims and the villains have
been drawn and then
we just change up the narrative in order
we just change up the facts in order to
match the narrative
we're gonna see this in in just one
second and it really is egregious
it's it's creating excuses for people to
burn cities which is
terrible and if you're a member of the
political class it is literally your job
to prevent this from happening
this is the only reason that you're in
government is to prevent people from
doing violence to one another and
violating each other's rights that is
your only reason for being in government
and yet your suggestion is that riots
are somehow justified because america is
a deeply horrible terrible very evil
place
with no evidence yet in this case none
by the way we still don't know if derek
shalvin
murdered george floyd first of all
whether he murdered him and the
autopsies are conflicting but we still
don't know whether that had anything to
do with race there is no evidence it had
to do with race rather than just police
brutality
it doesn't matter the nerve's already
been set and once the narrative is set
it cannot be unsaid we're going to get
to more of this in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that the 2020
election is about turnout
our opponents have their get out the
vote machine good thing is that
conservatives have one too i'm
supporting a massive
get out the vote effort of our own
sponsored by my friends over at job
creators network here's how it works you
go to 10420.com
you take the 10 for 20 pledge you'll
receive a link that'll give you the most
trusted voting information and tools you
can use to join the largest conservative
get out the vote effort ever
you'll be contacted by email and asked
to send a link and message to 10 people
you know
who care about america family and
neighbors church and work friends
they make sure they sign the pledge and
get the information they need to vote in
person or
by mail the fact is the the turnout in
this election is going to matter an
awful lot folks on the left are spending
an incredible amount of money to ensure
that their turnout is very high in this
election
we need a conservative get out the vote
effort and that is what 10420.com
is go to 10420.com take the pledge right
now
don't let our political opponents
outwork us do your part go to 10420.com
now that is the number 10
for the number 20.com 10420.com
go check them out right now 10420.com
get involved
in boosting the get out the vote effort
for conservatives okay so
how do our absolutely responsible
politicians respond to all of this
in the least responsible possible way
and truly it's disgusting when you have
public officials
who are backing a narrative without the
evidence in it's
it's horrifying so governor tony evers
who is the governor of the state of
wisconsin
right he's the governor where this
happened here's what he said
he says while we do not have all the
details yet what we know for certain is
that he is not the first black man or
person
to have been shot or injured or
mercilessly killed at the hands of
individuals in law enforcement in our
state
or our country do you understand how
deeply horrifying that statement is from
a politician
well we don't know anything about this
shooting we do know that all of these
terrible things have happened
in the past what what i mean seriously
what
so you have a situation where you don't
know whether a murder occurred or
whether a justified shooting occurred
and you just lump it in with all of the
racial murders of the past in the united
states
without any evidence in yet without any
investigation yet without any knowledge
of who the officer
is without any discussion of who the
suspect is without any discussion of the
situation surrounding the the officer
and the suspect
that's just how it that that is the only
thing that we know
right is that we know that america is a
deeply horrible racist place it's not
just the governor of the state it is his
responsibility to keep his state from
burning
it is his responsibility and he has
completely betrayed that responsibility
it's not just him it's politicians
across
the democratic spectrum jamal bowman who
just won a contested primary in new york
he just beat elliott engel
so he's going to enter congress that's a
very democratic district he tweeted out
three boys just saw their father shot
seven times in the back by police
no gun no struggle he was just walking
away
praying for jacob blake to make a speedy
and full recovery the issue is systemic
the senate needs to respond boldly and
humanely this is why we scream blm
no gun no struggle how do you know that
how does he know like seriously how do
we know
we don't know yet maybe maybe that's
true maybe that's not i don't know
he doesn't know it does not matter i
mean literally it doesn't matter if it
turns out there was a gun in the car and
this guy was reaching for the gun in the
car
they'll just say well they didn't know
there was a gun in the car so why did he
why did they shoot him why didn't they
tase him why didn't they tackle him
all of our newfound police experts who
have put their lives on the line to
protect their communities zero percent
it's very exciting stuff to watch our
politicians virtue signal at the expense
of police officers without any evidence
mayor lori lightfoot who has watched her
city burn
the same mayor lori lightfoot by the way
who recently
defended a ban on protesters on her
block she literally was fine with
chicago's loop being burned out
but she has allowed the chicago police
department to ban
protesters being able to demonstrate on
the block where she lives she told
reporters last thursday she and her
family at times required heightened
security because of the threats she
receives daily
lightfoot refused to elaborate on the
specific threats she receives them daily
against herself
her wife and her home she says she's i
think residents of the city
understanding the nature of the threats
that we are receiving on a daily basis
on a daily basis
understand i have a right to make sure
that my home is secure
oh really lori lightfoot so you have a
right to expect that your home is secure
but nobody else's home is secure just
you just you we had the same thing with
jenny durkin the mayor of seattle
in the middle of chaz chop when they set
up the separate republic in the middle
of seattle where people's businesses
were overrun
by an actual anti-government
anti-american rebellion
and she allowed that to happen for weeks
on end
she only got pissed when people started
marching on her home
in portland we've seen mayor ted wheeler
allow
people's businesses their homes to be
threatened we're seeing in washington dc
we're sitting in new york we're seeing
it in los angeles we're seeing all this
stuff happen
the only people who matter are our
political class only our political class
matter they get to say whatever
irresponsible insane thing they want to
say but they are protected so they're
fine
mayor lori lightfoot her house is
protected doesn't matter the chicago
loop gets
basically ransacked so what did she
tweet about this
quote yesterday in wisconsin a police
officer shot jacob blake an unarmed
black man
a father seven times in the back i am
deeply disturbed by the video capturing
part of the incident
i urge civil and criminal authorities to
pursue an immediate and thorough
investigation of the shooting first of
all they are doing an immediate and
thorough investigation of the shooting
second of all she's disturbed by the
video capturing part of the incident
if you don't have the whole incident
then sure that part of the video
is disturbing i mean whenever somebody
gets shot on video it's disturbing
but wouldn't you want to have like the
whole video when you want to know all
the circumstances
and it doesn't matter because she's
already characterized the situation
it's a police officer shooting jacob
blake an unarmed black man again we
don't know if he was unarmed
a father seven times in the back and
they won't mention the fact
you know of the of the prior criminal
record like if you're going to take into
account only the things that we know
then perhaps the prior criminal record
goes into the officers thinking they
pull up a rap sheet on the guy while
they're driving to the place perhaps i
mean we don't know the answer to any of
that doesn't justify the shooting
yet we don't know but that's the whole
point we don't freaking know
i'm saying we don't know why can't these
people say we don't know and the answer
is because the narrative matters
way more way more than the actual facts
of the case representative joe kennedy
who's running for senate in
massachusetts he tweeted out
there will be no end to the police
brutality and white supremacy black
americans confront on a daily basis
without action and real change jacob
blake an entire nation is praying for
you he literally does not know
what happened here because no one knows
what happened here i didn't realize that
joe kennedy was now god
there will be no ends the police
brutality and white supremacy
black americans confront on a daily
basis no end to it this is like when
michelle obama said at the convention
last week there's a never-ending list of
black people shot by please nope that
that list ends it turns out that list
ends it turns out the list of unarmed
black man shot unjustifiably by police
is in like low double digits and even
that is disputed it's the washington
post database so it turns out that list
has an end
joe kennedy saying there's no end to
police brutality and white supremacy
weird because there was a gallup poll
that was done two weeks ago that say 81
percent of black americans want the same
level
of policing in their communities or more
policing in their communities
which is a weird thing to want if you
are constantly being targeted by the
police
on on racial basis our politicians are
so damned irresponsible
so unbelievably irresponsible we still
don't know what happened here but none
of that matters
none of that matters and these riots are
now taking place in major cities across
the country
it's it's horrifying i mean truly we're
going to get some more of this
in just one second first let's talk
about
why exactly you're paying too much for
your cell phone bill there is no reason
to do that you may assume your cell
phone bill will always cost exactly what
it cost but that's not true there are
easy savings
you can find right now who's your
wireless provider att verizon t-mobile
what if i told you pure talk usa
uses the exact same network as one of
those carriers same tower same exact
coverage but literally cost you half
how do they make it so affordable well
there are no retail stores so low
overhead you're not funding their
billion dollar ad campaigns you're only
paying for the data you need no contract
no excessive fees
you'll enjoy unlimited talk text and two
gigs of data all for just 20 bucks a
month
that's right the average person is
saving 400 a year on their wireless bill
when they switch to pure talk usa so
grab that mobile phone style pound 250
say ben
shapiro when you do you have 250 bucks
off any iphone
including the brand new iphone se again
that is pound two five zero
say keyword ben shapiro pound two five
zero say keyword ben shapiro to get
started with pure talk usa you're paying
too much money for your cell phone bill
you're probably not using the unlimited
data that you are paying for
so why not cut that cell phone bill down
there is no reason to be spending 400
bucks extra a year
on your wireless bill go check out pure
talk usa by dialing pound 250 and saying
ben shapiro okay so are deeply
irresponsible politicians
across the united states there was all
this violence in wisconsin last night
the violence continues
in places like denver so denver is a new
site of violence
according to cbs local in denver denver
city leaders hosted a news conference on
sunday to discuss arrest and destruction
from riots on saturday night
a group of about 50 to 75 people rioted
outside the denver police department
headquarters
according to murphy robinson denver's
public safety director they brought
weapons to the table they had guns they
brought explosives
axes machetes and had one in 10 purpose
and that was harm to our officers
i want these anarchists to hear me
clearly and loudly this will not be
tolerated in our city you are not
welcome here
robinson went on to say the city plans
to do everything in its power to stop
these violent acts he said effective
immediately i'm suspending the command
pr bond
jail inmate cap i put in place due to
cover 19 which
basically allowed people to just be
released from jail
the cap aimed to prevent the spread of
coronavirus in the jail
multiple businesses suffer damage
including the quiznos so that was
exciting black block was just running
around smashing
businesses black block is of course an
anarchist group
robinson by the way is black he says i
want to speak to you as a black man and
as a denver native
the narrative that these anarchists are
marching for justice for black lives is
frankly false the public needs to know
you do not represent us
stop using the color of my skin to tear
up my city
so denver becomes yet another city
overrun by anarchists and rioters and
looters declaring themselves in support
of black lives matter
also remember that time that the federal
officers were largely removed from
portland and then portland continued to
burn we are now
in the 13th straight week of riots in
portland so well done mayor ted wheeler
and the
portland police department that has been
hamstrung by this garbage mayor
according to kgw 8 protests in portland
have continued for the 13th straight
week
since the death of george floyd
demonstrators have taken to the streets
to protest systematic racism
police brutality and a call to defund
portland police department
saturday night about 250 protesters
gathered at normandale park in portland
before a direct action march
the march calls for the complete
abolition of police and prisons which
sounds like a great plan while you're
burning the entire city to the ground
you stupid pieces
journalists on the scene are reporting
that portland police would not let the
protesters cross
in some areas the police department said
in a statement early sunday morning to
prevent anyone from getting hurt due to
vehicles
because there were four vehicles that
refused uh that approached officers and
refused to move
because the officers had set up a line
in front of the cars a sergeant deflated
two tires on one of the vehicles the
other vehicles then complied with orders
to leave
the portland police department said the
incident commander tried to prevent
protesters from marching
to the penumbra kelly building because
it had been the target of rioters on
multiple occasions over the past
few months apparently someone rolled a
mock guillotine with a stuffed bear into
the street i don't know what
paddington did exactly multiple u.s
flags and the bear were then burned
well i don't know what the bear did like
that bearer seems to be taking the brunt
of it paint balloons were hurled at
officers green lasers were pointed at
law enforcement to try and blind them
and uh large rocks were thrown at police
officers as well so
things are going great over in portland
as per our usual arrangement
okay all of which suggest that americans
might want to care what's happening in
their major cities and they might want
to care about the deep
and disgusting irresponsibility of their
major public officials who have declared
that the facts do not matter that the
cops are always bad
and in any disputed circumstances you
can simply assume that it is a
reinforcement of the narrative that
america is systemically evil and black
people
are systemically put upon by the system
of the united states
that is the narrative that is now being
drawn you can see the democratic
politicians
caving to this so kamala harris our
wonderful vice presidential candidate in
the democratic party she was asked over
the weekend about the fact
that in prior iterations of kamala
harris she has called for more policing
in high crime communities because that
is in fact the only way
that you increase the both the life
expectancy and the benefits of living in
the united states for people who want to
live in a law abiding community you make
sure that they can actually call on the
cops
you want to know why high crime areas
are high crime because they're not
enough police officers they're not
because there are too few police
not because not because you want to get
rid of the police
so here is kamala harris being asked
about how
she used to claim that we need more
police officers in high crime areas and
here she is saying well
you know i'm going to avoid all that i'm
just going to talk about black lives
matter and how there's an entrenched
status quo
and here's her anti-cop position
you conclude by saying that you wanted
to see more police
on the street do you still feel that way
listen i think that there is no question
first of all
when i wrote that book um
we black lives matter did not exist
and i give full credit to the brilliance
of that movement in terms of what it has
done to advance
a conversation that needed to happen a
long time ago
what black lives matter has done as a
movement
has been to be a counter force against
a very entrenched status quo around the
criminal justice system in america
unbelievable what what an unbelievable
unbelievably manipulative hypocrite this
person is
my goodness this is a person who was a
prosecutor and she was pro-cop
up until the point where it became
politically non-beneficial for her to be
a prosecutor and pro-cop
and then all of a sudden she shifts into
black lives matter is a wonderful
counterforce
okay i understand protesting against
police brutality
i understand wanting to relieve
qualified immunity i've talked about it
repeatedly on the show i've talked about
police unions i've talked about all
these things
but if you're going to claim that you no
longer need police in high crime
communities because black lives matter
is doing a good job
you're going to pretend that protests
and rioters have nothing to do with the
black lives matter movements we've been
seeing around the country
which is insane okay these are growing
out of black lives matter protests
it's funny how the media used to
maintain the stark separate division
between
rioters and protesters and then as soon
as the rioters and the protesters
started to gain the upper hand
and became nearly impossible to ignore
them then it became well maybe it's
justified
maybe it's kind of justified i'm we went
through four nights of democratic
national convention
last week in which rioters and looters
didn't exist they just didn't exist poof
they're gone
absolutely incredible and by the way do
i trust kamala harris
on race and racism in the united states
no i do not
i think she's a machiavellian
manipulative damned liar
how do i know that she's a liar i'll
show you in just one second i mean she's
a brutal liar we'll get to that in just
one second it's amazing she's being
upheld as an example of racial
uh of some sort of racial spokesperson
in the united states
considering how she has used the issue
of race in order to
either advance or not advance a
particular agenda it's really incredible
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about
the fact that there are people who are
interested in stealing your stuff and
they can do it without actually having
to break into your home
well the fact is that cover 19 how does
that have to do with losing your home
well it could have a lot to do with
losing your home the fbi reports that
cyber crime is up 75
since the virus hit one cyber crime you
should worry about is home title theft
legal documents to your home are now
kept online and cyber thieves
foreign and domestic know that if you
don't protect your home's title well
there is the possibility that something
bad could happen thieves could forge
your name on a quick claim deed
so somebody could actually just do that
and then sell your home they slap a fake
notary seal on it refile is the new
owner of the home
this is actually happening people then
they take out loans against the home
they leave you in debt
your bank may not protect you neither
does your insurance or common identity
theft guys for pennies a day home title
lock puts a virtual barrier around your
home's title
the instant they detect tampering they
shut it down so go check out
hometitlelock.com
register your address to see if you've
already been a victim of something like
this then use code shapiro for 30 free
days of protection that is code shapiro
at home
title lock dot com protect yourself
against hackers who could try and grab
the title to your home to make all sorts
of financial trouble for you
go to home title lock dot com again
that's home
title lock dot com use code shapiro for
30 free days
of protection okay so again kamala
harris what an awful hypocrite
she spends years as tough prosecutor
cracking down on crime and then
the minute she becomes a vice
presidential candidate black lives
matter is doing incredible work against
law enforcement all over the united
states
why don't i trust kamala harris on even
her even the authenticity of her
newfound
racial progressivism because she's just
she's willing to say literally anything
just a damn hypocrite okay so you
remember early on in the primary race
when she labeled joe biden racist she
suggested that joe biden was trying to
stop little girls like her from
attending
interracial schools from attending
integrated schools integrated public
schools right she even sold shirts that
said
a little girl like me and that was her
thing so she was asked about this
on abc okay so she's on abc news and
she's asked specifically about this
and here is her answer okay she's she's
willing to say anything our politicians
are willing to say anything
okay they're not j so many of these
politicians are not genuine about
solving racial problems in this country
if you want to solve racial problems in
this country you know what you do you
actually look at the conditions under
which racial problems become a problem
you look at behavior you look at the
fact that high crime communities need
more cops
you look at the fact that people need
school choice you look at the fact that
we need more fathers in communities
you look at the fact that we need to
incentivize people to stay in school
right these are all systemic problems
that much more greatly affect
black americans than the prevalence of
cops in communities or by the way
pulling cops from the communities
but kamala harris is not willing to talk
about anything that's not convenient to
kamala harris so here's kamala harris
over the weekend
being asked specifically about basically
implying joe biden is a racist
what uh i can't believe that people
trust our politicians i cannot believe
it frankly here's kamala
can't get past the debate a lot of
people cannot
let that go the way you challenged him
so
how did you go from there to here
i want joe biden to be the next
president
of the united states i believe in joe
biden
i believe in his perspective and frankly
i think that conversation is a
distraction
from what we need to accomplish right
now and what we need to do
these are the people you trust don't
worry if she tweets about
about the this this person who's shot
she tweets about jacob blake
then magically everybody will believe
that she's empathic about these issues
but there she is basically saying yeah
sure i called them a racist but you know
what it doesn't matter anymore because
i'm trying to get ahead
does it really what does it really
matter the the manipulation of the
narrative by members of the media for
political gain by members of our
political class for political gain and
then the cities burn
their real-life consequences to this
stuff there are people who suffer
because of this stuff there are people
who die because of this stuff
it is it is incredible i'm not saying
people die because of kamala harris's
commentary
i'm saying that people die when you
forward the narrative that america is a
deeply
racist systemically evil place and then
people riot on that basis
i'm saying that these things have
consequences because they do
we're watching the consequences in the
streets every night in major cities
around the country
we're watching it happen and the media
just forward these narratives
they forward the narratives because the
narratives not only they believe in them
but they also
allow people to to restructure american
society along the lines that they wish
to see
how far does some of this racial
rhetoric go well if you look at our
media our media are even
worse than our political class because
the media at least supposedly have an
incentive to tell the truth but
apparently not
remember that time that jamel hill so
she's a commentator i at least
acknowledge she's not an objective
journalist right she's a she's an
opinion person
so opinion person jamel hill who has
opinions professionally which is fine i
also have opinions professionally
jamel hill used to be hired by espn and
then she was let go because she was
even too old for the for for msnbc with
footballs then she was hired by the
atlantic remember the atlantic
was a place that was so establishment
that kevin williamson was too much for
them kevin williamson of national review
well now she writes for the atlantic
and she tweeted out over the weekend
quote been reading isabelle wilkerson's
new book
cast right this is the hot new book
pushed by oprah winfrey that suggests
that america
is basically like the indian caste
system which is why of course
untouchables have been elected to the
highest leadership positions in india
oh wait they haven't in the united
states we've had a black president
elected overwhelmingly twice
but she has been reading isbo
wilkerson's new book cast and if you
weren't of the opinion that the united
states wasn't nearly as bad as nazi
germany
how wrong you are can't encourage you
enough to read this masterpiece now
um it seems to me that there were some
differences between the united states
and a nazi germany
even during the worst of jim crow such
as we didn't murder six million black
people in the united states in a
systemic genocide that seems like a
minor difference that you might want to
note there does not excuse jim crow
it does not excuse the evils of american
racism but the narrative
drawn that america is just like nazi
germany or like the caste system in
india
is so patently absurd on its face and
yet that gets pushed
okay that that narrative is being pushed
by by major publications it's being
pushed
by members of the media other racial
narratives that are being pushed
is that racism only works in one
direction so if you're a racist
in another direction then anything can
be racism except for
certain things right so for example
democrats are now suggesting that if you
mispronounce kamala harris's name that
is racist that's absurd
maybe you just mispronounced her name
it's not the easiest name to pronounce
but this has become a democratic talking
point it's racist to mispronounce kamala
harris's name
there's literally an article from the ap
about this over the weekend
when top republicans including president
donald trump and vice president mike
pence mispronounced democratic vice
presidential
can nominee kamala harris's first name
it's not just disrespectful
it's racist according to the democrats
because pronounced kamala not kamala
i mean like comma so that let's just say
let's point out okay here here's the new
standard from the narrative centers in
american politics you don't need
evidence
when there is an interracial shooting of
a white police officer
on a black person then you don't need
evidence it is
purely in evidence of america's systemic
racism if a black person shoots a white
person we just don't report it in the
united states it doesn't make any dent
at all the media just it's not a
national story because obviously
racism doesn't exist on in that
direction it's just
it's not something we care about america
is just like nazi germany
except if a democrat gets elected then
it's all wonder and light as joe biden
said
how do we know by the way that racism
only exists on on one side according to
this narrative
so over the weekend there was an nba
player
this this guy's name is montrezl herrell
montrell harrell he plays for the los
angeles clippers
and there is a european origin player
named luca doncic and probably
pronouncing his name incorrectly plays
for the dallas mavericks tremendous
player
and in the middle of the game between
the mavericks and the clippers
this montrel harrell person
he called he called doncic a
ass white boy that is a direct
quote right you can see it happening
on tape right ass white boy
so what did the nba do about this well
the nba did nothing about this
nothing literally nothing they said we
had a conversation
a conversation right because racism
doesn't exist in this direction
doc rivers who's the coach of the la
clippers here's what doc rivers
had to say about this particular quote
quote
you just have to be careful they were
both talking i don't think luca was
saying anything racial but he was
swearing
so they were both doing it they were
both doing it
so swearing is now the same as a racial
slur is what is what we've been told in
fact
what doc river says this wasn't even a
racial slur when you say ass white
boy it has nothing to do with color
he says it's an emotional game it's a
playground game out there in the
playoffs i said to him hey i don't think
he meant anything racially by it he said
white boy but i don't think there was
anything racial intended
which is a weird way to say something
non-racial but we are in a very
heightened climate you have to be
careful
trey was the first one to say that he
said i didn't mean that radically
i didn't mean that racially and i said
it doesn't matter it's what's perceived
make sure you do the right thing now
listen
i'm fine with everybody lightening up on
their reactions
to this kind of stuff i am but we are
now living in a society where we are
told that without evidence racism
is the defining factor of american life
and that every disparity is attributable
to american racism
but if a black person says to a white
person bitch-ass white boy it is
inherently non-racial
does this sound like a consistent
standard to you does this sound
logical to you in any way or does it
sound like a narrative is being drawn
and that the narrative
doesn't care about the evidence the
evidence simply doesn't matter all that
matters in the end is the narrative
end of story america's systemically
racist white people are systemically
discriminating against
black people black people are incapable
of being racist by the way this is one
of the points
of the so-called anti-racism contentions
is that racism isn't just discrimination
racism is discrimination combined with
power
and because white people hold the power
based on the
perverse conspiratorial world view of
the anti-racists that means that only
white people can be racist and you also
don't need evidence of racism in order
to claim racism
the predictable result of this is to
divide americans and to make americans
more polarized
the the way that normal people should
act about this stuff is to look at each
other as individuals i know that's
verboten we're not allowed to do that
anymore look at each other as
individuals look at each indiv
each individual incident based on its
fact pattern but we just don't do it
it's not worthwhile anymore so we just
don't do it
okay in a second we're gonna get to the
rnc because this is going to be one of
the themes of the rnc
and frankly it should be one of the
themes of the rnc the city's burning
seems like a rather major theme that
democrats completely elided
for eight long hours of prime time dnc
last week we learned that the black
lives matter movement
is completely wonderful and great and
the protesters are the best of us as
barack obama suggested
the riots and the looting don't exist
and america's systemically racist except
if joe biden gets elected in which case
he brings the light the 80 year old
white man
he brings the light and everything is
all better
even if you're a black lives matter
protestor i wonder if you believe the
crap that's being fed to you about how
joe biden an 80 year old an octogenarian
white man who used to work with
segregationist senators
is going to heal all racial wounds in
the country are you that much of a
sucker if you're on the hard left
seriously
we'll get to more of this in just one
second we get to the rnc which begins
tonight but first imagine you're walking
through a parking lot you're with your
kids and as you approach your car
you see somebody closing in and
something seems wrong so you calmly move
in front of your kids and you turn
toward
this person and the person starts to
move toward their own gun
the person is now 30 feet away you don't
make a move yet but you can feel that
you have a gun on your hip
and so you say stay back and then the
attacker understands what criminals
comprehend he's picked the wrong target
and he turns around
and your kid says what's wrong you say
nothing everything is fine in this day
and age
you may need a gun to protect your
family and yourself and this is
unfortunately becoming more and more
common in major cities across the united
states
this is why you should be a responsible
gun owner one of the purposes of
responsibly owning and using a gun is to
make sure you never have to use a gun
get your 100 free copy
of the complete concealed carry and
family defense guide from the u.s
concealed carry association
it is 164 pages it comes with a bonus
audio version so you can listen
whenever you want just text protect to
it's not just important to own a firearm
you actually have to know how to use it
and
how to handle it so that you never have
to use it that's the point you'll get
instant access and a chance to win a
thousand bucks when you text protect to
222 so you can buy a gun to protect your
family text protect to 87 222
right now to get that free complete
concealed carry on a family defense
guide from the uscca text protect at 87
222 right now
in just one second we're going to get to
the rnc because the rnc begins tonight
and you can bet
that some of the thematics are going to
focus in on the burning of america's
major cities
but first if you haven't heard by now
joe biden is officially the democratic
party's presidential nominee for 2020
we know because we made our own matt
walsh suffer through his acceptance
speech at the dnc
matt is still unhappy about this in fact
he is cowering in his own basement right
now i believe he's in like fetal
position crying
however we were not just torturing matt
for fun i mean we were but
also he was hosting all access live over
at dailywire.com with our all-access
members
daily wire's most exclusive membership
tier all access members get to join
these
access live sessions where one of us
hosts every night
one of us will jump on every night to
chat with you both in live stream
and in the comments usually the sessions
are casual hangouts on special occasions
we will host watch parties like matt's
last week
again this thursday august 27th we'll be
doing it live streaming an all-access
live watch party for the final night of
the rnc hosted by none other than the
exquirable michael knowles i have a
prediction he will like president
trump's speech
the live stream will start at 8 45 pm
eastern 5 45 pm pacific a few minutes
before the convention kicks off
all access membership also features not
one but two leftist tears tumblers with
your membership as well as early
sometimes exclusive access
to new daily wire products so head on
over to dailywire.com right now get 20
off all access with coupon code access
that is dailywire.com
shapiro with coupon code access to get
20 off your membership you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast
in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so the rnc tonight i'm sure is
going to focus in on the riots and the
looting
and that is not a politically driven
decision
by itself i mean the fact is that when
you go eight hours of democratic
national convention time and nobody can
condemn antifa
nobody can condemn the black lives
matter looters and writers not the
protesters the writers and the looters
right some of whom are indeed protesters
who morph into rioters and looters when
it becomes time
they can pretend for a full eight hours
of prime time this stuff doesn't exist
and then they can have kamala harris go
on national television and say that the
blm movement is pushing us toward a
better america and i'm wondering how
does it feel like america is getting
better over the past several months
if it does i'm just wondering what is
your evidence of this
like seriously are race relations better
in the country do you feel like we've
moved
toward actual solutions or does it turn
out that when senator tim scott the
black republican from south carolina
proposes an actual police reform bill
and democrats filibuster the thing to
prevent a solution
this is really much more about narrative
drawing and pure politics than it is
about solving problems
so as it turns out americans do in fact
care
about what is happening right now in
america's major cities there's a new
gallup poll out
and it shows that 59 of americans
say that they are concerned about the
levels of violent crime that are
happening in america's major cities and
the burning of america's major cities
that's just slightly lower than the 63
of americans who say that coronavirus is
one of their top priorities so this is a
major issue the media have completely
downplayed it the media have completely
ignored it
and you can bet your bottom dollar that
republicans are going to focus on it at
the rnc
which they absolutely should as
democratic politicians continue to
simply without evidence suggest that
america is an evil systemically racist
caste system
according to the wall street journal
there are some signs of life for the
trump campaign
there's a new poll from the wall street
journal nbc news
the president's share of support which
is at 41 has not topped 44
this year against joe biden he trails
the former vp in aggregated polling of
most
battleground states although his deficit
is smaller than is in national polls but
his position may be stronger than head's
head polling shows at this point in the
last election
trump trails his democratic opponent by
nine percentage points in journal nbc
news polling he still does
his public image has actually picked up
some shine more voters saw trump in a
negative light than a positive one
in the most recent poll by a margin of
about 12 percentage points but
at this point four years ago the
negative outnumbered the positive by 33
percentage
points he apparently has an improved
image among white voters
he lags behind his 2016 vote share as
recorded by exit polls
but white voters in the most recent
journal nbc news survey were divided
almost equally between positive and
negative
views of the president's about 20 points
higher than he was doing last time
around he's holding steady with
hispanics as well
some 31 percent of hispanics say they
will back the president which is
slightly higher
than the 28 who voted for him in 2016.
republican intensity is also beginning
to build
and apparently up for grabs voters are
still leaning republican which is good
news for
for him according to that journal nbc
news survey in july they looked at
voters who haven't ruled out either
candidate are in play
those voters as a group have
characteristics that suggest they are
open to trump and his party according to
the wall street journal
some 22 percent have a positive image of
trump only 11
have a positive image of joe biden they
prefer a candidate who will confront the
washington establishment which is one of
trump's key pitches and of course trump
still leads on the economy and voters
dislike both parties so
this election is not quite over yet so
you can expect
that the president is going to focus in
on two things one
his own ubiquity right he's going to
focus in on that
and he's going to focus in on the crime
issues that have been plaguing america's
major cities apparently he's going to
speak every single night at the rnc
now i don't know whether that is a
particularly good strategy you usually
want to build up some sort of drama
but i guess that look trump knows more
about reality tv than virtually anybody
alive i mean the man was this is one of
the areas where trump was successful
area other areas he has exaggerated his
success the man was a very very
successful reality tv host so he knows
how this stuff works he's probably
figuring listen
not everybody's gonna watch last night
we're gonna have different audiences
every night so i'll show up every single
night
according to jason miller he said you'll
have president trump speaking at various
parts for each of the knights miller
said that the
rnc will tell a beautiful story miller
said one of the things you're going to
see this week is a complete change in
the perception
that the media tries to tell about what
a trump supporter looks like or who a
trump supporter is we're going to talk
about the american story we're going to
see a great uplifting message from the
president and from our allies
and chuck when i tell you some of these
stories you hear they're going to be
some breakout stars some people you
would not expect to be supporters of the
president it's going to be a very
beautiful story so here are some of the
people who are going to be appearing
so you're going to get senator tim scott
of south carolina who will appear which
is
you know something that that was a
controversial you're going to get
steve scalise of louisiana matt getz of
course of florida is a big fan of the
president obviously representative jim
jordan of ohio
nikki haley will be there you're going
to see the rnc chairwoman of course
and then you're going to see amy johnson
ford who's one of the people who's
helped out by criminal justice reform
i believe uh you're going to see kim
klasik who is a candidate
in baltimore she cut a video that went
absolutely viral talking about
how horribly baltimore has been run for
years you'll see mark and patricia
mccloskey that was that couple in st
louis were brought up on charges for
defending their property
you will see andrew pollock who had a
relative who was
murdered in a mass shooting and has been
a big supporter of the president
those are the monday speakers on tuesday
you're going to see
first lady melania trump mike pompeo
senator rand paul will be appearing
you will see a group of nick sandman
who's
the kid who is targeted in the covington
catholic scandal
and then there are a bunch of names that
i really don't know and who i'm sure we
will get to see over the course of time
i believe that uh the uh the entire
johnson family basically is showing up
one is speaking every night
alice johnson was one of the lead
figures in the criminal justice reform
if i got that name
wrong in the first place so it'll be
interesting to see how they program this
thing
and apparently they're banking on some
surprises
that will change the narrative a little
bit according to bloomberg
trump said that he's going to go live as
much as humanly possible
he's also teasing the promise of at
least a few surprises
the convention represents one of trump's
last chances to make the case and write
the sputtering campaign look the bottom
line is what he needs to focus in on is
the unrest in america's major cities
and i'm frankly shocked that he has not
done a better job of touting
his actual record on covid so the
president has said many stupid things
over the course of the past six months
on covet but the actual record of the
administration and getting governors
what they want
is pretty good like i if they do not
have some time
in this prime time convention just a
mash-up of all the democratic governors
saying that trump gave them what they
need
that is political malpractice i've been
saying it for weeks at this point
i'm shocked they have not done it so far
all of which led by the way
the president to make an announcement
over the weekend that was highly
controversial because it looks like he's
politicizing
the pursuit of solutions on covet 19.
basically the day before the convention
starts
trump issued an emergency used
authorization for blood plasma he called
it transformative
national science shows that it may have
some effects blood plasma
there's a study from the mayo clinic
that shows that it'll have some effect
is it is it a cure-all no
uh is it an effective therapeutic uh the
the evidence appears to be yes although
the evidence is still coming in
and so there's been a lot of controversy
over whether trump is rushing the
emergency use authorization for blood
plasma for political reasons
doing it the day before the rnc
certainly suggests that right on a
political level it's just
it seems like manipulative to do that
period
now again i think blood plasma has been
used in a variety of treatments so it
really is not all that controversial
medically
but it looks like you are you are
pushing for a solution before the rnc
for political purposes
uh and uh you make it pretty transparent
when you do it the day before the rnc
here was trump
over the weekend today i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
the fda has issued an emergency
use authorization and
that's such a a powerful term emergency
use
authorization for a treatment known as
convalescent plasma
this is a powerful therapy
that transfuses very very strong
antibodies
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection
so frankly this is a good thing as a as
a full-time libertarian
uh i've always had serious problems with
the fda i i don't think you need a
federal government agency slowing up
medications
for two three years it turns out there's
legal liability that attaches to putting
out bad drugs in the public marketplace
and you know who knows that the drug
companies and the the very idea that you
have to go through
some sort of fda approval process in
order for there to be emergency blood uh
convalescent blood plasma authorization
seems to me foolish in the extreme
um but doing this the day before the rnc
and then declaring it a breakthrough
obviously looks very political it also
looks political when the president
starts
tweeting about how his own
administration is blocking him
so on saturday trump suggested that
employees at the fda were sabotaging his
re-election by slowing down coronavirus
research
he said members of the deep state at the
fbi were making it hard for drug
companies to quote unquote get people in
order to test the vaccines and the
therapeutics and obviously want to delay
progress until after the november third
election day and the evidence of this uh
i have not seen
it seems to me that if you are in the
fda you probably don't want to slow down
the collection of information about
vaccines and
again i've seen no evidence of that the
president is always saying the quiet
part out loud
and to suggest that your own
administration is blocking you from from
pushing forward
as hard as you can is silly especially
because it makes it look as though okay
fine so then take control
then take control i mean seriously if
you believe that take control
the fact is that he doesn't need to do
any of this what he needs to do is point
out the fact
that when the media were focused on
ventilators he got people the
ventilators when they were focused on
ppe he got people to pbe remember how
ppe and ventilators were like case
number one and one a and how trump was
doing a bad job
and then he got all the ventilators and
all the ppe and then it just disappeared
well now he's pushed forward with warp
speed on the vaccine
and there's good information coming out
that these vaccines may be effective by
the end of the year which would be
frankly miraculous because usually it
takes a decade to develop an effective
vaccine
on diseases and that'd be pretty like i
don't understand why he's telling a
story about an fda trying to obscure the
process when he could be telling a story
about how he's done a pretty good job
of trying to ensure that everybody gets
what they need and he could be telling
an even better story about how the
democrats want to shut the entire
economy down again
i mean that's the best story here for
the republicans is we've been looking at
gradual reopening we've been getting
people what they need republican
governors
have been ensuring that the nursing
homes are protected
while also ensuring that people can go
out and live their lives and still have
death rates that are much lower than
blue states
like new jersey and new york and
massachusetts and connecticut and
meanwhile joe biden is openly talking
about shutting down the entire american
economy again
over the weekend i mean how is this not
a campaign ad over the weekend joe biden
said
that he would shut down the entire
american economy again over covet
which is patently crazy here's joe biden
would you be prepared to shut this
country down again
i would be prepared to do whatever it
takes to save lives because we cannot
get the country moving
until we control the virus that is the
fundamental flaw of this
administration's thinking to begin with
in order to keep the country running and
moving and the economy growing
and people employed you have to fix the
virus you have to deal with the virus
so if the scientists say shut it down i
would shut it down
i would shut it down ad i would shut it
down if the scientists say okay the
scientists are always going to say shut
it down because again if your job as a
scientist is to quote unquote prevent
the spread
and your job as a scientist is not to
take into account any countervailing
considerations like
kids not going to school like entire
economies dying like the fact that the
lockdowns have not been particularly
effective in general at doing anything
beyond delaying
people receiving the virus but they
certainly have not actually prevented
the virus from spreading in the long
term
locking down the entire american economy
at a time when there is no uptick in new
york there is no uptick in new jersey
there is no uptick in connecticut
the only places that are seeing uptake
all over the world are pl all over the
world
are places that have not been hit by the
virus yet i mean it's
why is the president not campaigning on
that that's what he should have been
saying over the weekend
what he should have been saying is joe
biden wants to shut it all down we need
to find a way to reopen americans want
to reopen
we're doing it safely we're doing it
securely and we've already seen it wayne
in places like arizona georgia and
florida
where the media have been telling you
that everybody's dying right that is the
campaign
that's the campaign okay meanwhile the
radicalism of the dnc
on full display continues to be on full
display
so over the weekend apparently the
biden campaign reversed itself
on whether linda sarsour is an
anti-semite i mean this is truly
incredible
so apparently over the weekend you
remember that linda sarsour was picked
as a delegate
for the she was picked as a delegate for
one of these
muslim caucuses and during the day part
of the
of the dnc and linda sarsour
is a virulent anti-semite and the bible
administration came out the biden
campaign came out
and they said well you know we don't
agree with linda sarsour
over the weekend top aides to
presidential candidate joe biden
apologized to arab and muslim democrats
according to middle east i.n.net
over an attack on linda sarsour by the
campaign
in a private call with dozens of
prominent activists on sunday ashley
allison national coalitions director for
the biden campaign said she was very
sorry
for the comments a campaign spokesperson
made against sarsour
top foreign policy adviser tony blinken
also expressed regret
over the incident during the virtual
meeting remember that time where they
said that the biden campaign
was fighting anti-semitism yeah
apparently not also it turns out
that at least six of the speakers at the
democratic national
convention are backers of louis
farrakhan including common
freddie haynes tamika mallory linda
sarsour james clyburn and cory booker
right all these people said that they
would meet with uh with
louis farrakhan so the democratic party
continues to be incredibly
radical good news however the democratic
party is also going to fund the post
office this was their big move over the
weekend
they passed a bill to not relieve
anyone's economic pains but to give 25
billion dollars to the post office to
alleviate a non-existent scandal
whereby the post office is out of money
and can't handle mail-in ballots
that was very important stuff but this
necessitated that the democrats pretend
the post office is good at its job so
nancy pelosi over the weekend
suggested no business in america would
be saddled with what we've saddled the
post office with which is patently crazy
it's not a business it's a service and
while we always want to subject every
federal dollar to the scrutiny
of what we're getting for it let us
remember
that it is a service no business that i
can think of would ever be
saddled with what we've done to the
postal service saying
that they in 19 2006 a bill passed
that said that that the postal service
should pay
75 years of its health benefits
in 10 years i mean who voted for that
again
the the complete restructuring of the
postal service's debt also you know the
postal service has been saddled with
complete government bailouts on every
front
on every front meanwhile by the way aoc
was speaking up about the post office
like the democrats focused in on the
most important parts
of american public life namely a service
that has been bankrupt for the last 14
years
and you can easily send mail through
other means including ups
and uh fedex here's here's aoc
the postal service is how is not only
how we send a ballot
it is how we get our medicine it is how
we send
rent checks it's where people are
getting their tax refunds
it is a core service of any
civilized society and an attack on our
postal service
and an attempt to dismantle our our
out of a selfish desire to sabotage our
democracy
and and maintain a grip on power is an
attack on all of
us uh good times good time by the way
joe biden has just come out with a
statement on jacob blake speaking of
responsible democrats joe biden your
responsible democrat here is his
statement on jacob blake just broke a
moment ago quote
yesterday in kenosha wisconsin jacob
jacob blake was shot seven times in the
back
as police attempted to restrain him from
getting into his car his children
watched from inside the car and
bystanders watched in disbelief
and this morning the nation wakes up yet
again with grief and outrage that yet
another black american is a victim of
excessive force
this calls for an immediate full and
transparent investigation and the
officers must be held accountable
these shots pierce the soul of our
nation jill and i pray for jacob's
recovery and for his children
equal justice has not been real for
black americans and so many others we
are at an inflection point
we must dismantle systemic racism it is
the urgent task before us we must fight
to honor the ideals
laid in the original american promise
which we are yet to attain that all men
and women are created equal but more
importantly that they must be treated
equally
does he have any evidence that we have
not heard about joe biden any evidence
at all that we have not heard about at
this point
the answer of course is no the answer of
course is no he does not know what
happened with jacob blake because you
don't know what happened with jacob like
because i don't know what happened with
jacob blake because no one knows what
happened
when you say specifically in your
statement that there has to be a full
transparent and immediate investigation
that suggests
you don't know what the hell is going on
and yet there you have it the former
vice president of the united states
being a racial demagogue on an issue
where he does not have evidence
but good news the media are focused in
not on the racial demagoguery and the
burning of america's
of american cities they are focused in
on really important things like the
white house rose garden renovations so
over the weekend the white house
released photos
of their renovation of the white house
rose garden they were they restored it
to the original sort of jackie o
state of the renovate of the rose garden
last month melania trump announced that
she was taking on the project
okay by by adding technical updates
apparently future presidents will be
able to use the space to broadcast
events and presidential
addresses there are serious drainage
problems and inaccessibility to disabled
people
and so they've added some new pastel
flowers
they have a diamond like shape of
boxwoods added a dozen crab apple trees
were removed and will be replanted
elsewhere
on the grounds also a seating area has
been removed and will
be replaced by a yet to be announced art
installation there's a three foot wide
limestone walking path bordering the
central lawn
that is supposed to make the garden more
accessible for people with disabilities
so good news apparently the democrats
have lost their minds over this
the howard feynman of newsweek uh
who has just lost it i mean really lost
it and he's an nbc news analyst
he tweeted out the trump family did its
best to turn the lovely rose garden into
a neo-fascist parade
ground a neo-fascist parade ground
howard feynman
kurt eichenwald who uh
is kind of a crazy person he tweeted out
i still find it unbelievable
that the first lady who has only been a
citizen since the middle of g w bush's
second term had the audacity to wreck
the rose garden
to pull up history dating back a
lifetime these trashy evil stupid people
need to get out of our house what goal
she has focusing in on all the important
issues like the white house at rose
garden
really well done everyone well done
everyone okay now i'd be remiss if i did
not make a very brief comment on the
kellyanne conway controversy that is the
controversy of the day so kellyanne
conway
has now quit the trump white house she's
going to leave by the end of the month
her husband george who's been involved
in the lincoln project which is a
which is a grifter scam on behalf of
democrats i say grifter scam because
supposedly
it is a conservative anti-trump
opposition except they are now endorsing
people
against susan collins in maine and so
george conway's been very anti-trump for
quite a long time there's obviously
enormous family family problems
happening they have a daughter a 15 year
old daughter who is 15 she's trying to
emancipate from her parents right now
she posts all of these
these tick tock videos and the social
media videos and the left loves them
because it is her
basically crapping on her mom
and they never think hey wait a second
maybe a 15 year old is not the most
reliable source on family relations and
maybe also we should be
letting 15 year olds have their privacy
even if they wish to remove
their privacy from themselves even if
they wish to alienate their own privacy
so now she she wrote on twitter that um
apparently daughter claudia had a
deleted video where she accused her
parents of physical abuse
and asking for emancipation she said
that her mom was very physically abusive
very very verbally abusive she said at
one point her mom had been
she said my mom got me arrested she
hasn't provided any evidence of this so
this is all really sad anybody who is
laughing over it
is making a very large scale mistake
family problems are not generally
something
uh to laugh at it's uh it's one thing if
you're talking about adults once the
kids get involved then it really is not
something to laugh at so
hopefully the conway family gets it
together and i'm glad for kellyanne and
for george that they're leaving
their sort of public spat to the side
and trying to rebuild whatever is left
of their
family dynamic alrighty so we'll be back
here later today with two additional
hours of content there'll be a lot more
then
also we'll back we'll be back here
tomorrow morning so stick around for
that go subscribe over at dailywire.com
pick up a copy
of my more relevant than ever book how
to destroy america in three easy steps
you're listening to the shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowski our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching
and the moon is turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton
you